hey wassup guys my name is a cello and
over the next few days I'm gonna be
making a series of videos that will
hopefully help you out with blood and
air so what is love them they're okay a
lot of people probably don't know what
Londonderry is let them there is a game
programming competition that goes over
48 hours so essentially you have 48
hours to make a game based on a
particular theme and for the main
competition kind of segment of that that
competition I guess because there's two
there's two different passes competition
there's the compr which is the
competition one and then there's the jam
and they have different rules but
essentially the we're what kind of got
to be focusing on the combo one because
that's the one that is actually I guess
the the serious one so you have 48 hours
to make a game on a theme that is
released when the competition starts and
essentially you can't use any like
proprietary libraries or anything and
you have to make everything from scratch
within 48 hours you can't use graphics
and assets and code that you've done
earlier you can use open source
libraries and stuff like that as long as
you mention them etc but the point is
that yeah you have 48 hours to make a
game so these these tip videos are gonna
hopefully be designed to help you guys
out with making the game look this is
one of those things that has been
requested pretty much every dime every
time I do I do do love them there I am
doing loading there
29 is it I don't know I'm doing this
Laden data once in December 2013 and
I'll be live streaming it on twitch.tv
force at the Cherno of course and the
link to that will be in the description
and make sure you follow me on twitter
twitter campos dr. chan again link in
the description so you know why i start
streaming stuff like that anyway let's
get on to these tips so first of all
this video is gonna be about planning
okay so to plan full of them dare right
to plan for and and by the way these
tips are actually going to be helping
you well at least this one during the
competition not really before the
competition so basically as soon as you
get the theme let's think about the
planning okay so how can you plan your
entry your game essentially so first of
all you have to think about why are you
doing what I'm dead right why are you
doing this okay I mean there's a lot of
reasons and most of them are adequate I
guess you could be doing a lot of meant
this is really important as well cuz
that's gonna affect the entire approach
that you take to this if you're doing
let them dare to let's just say to test
yourself if you can make a game in 48
hours that is playable that's fine
obviously there are other reasons such
as you know you want to win as and you
want to maybe come in the top 10 or
whatever or win the competition that's a
different approach of course and then
another very common one is you just want
to basically test out a particular I
guess programming strategy as well so no
it's something like that so what I mean
by that is you've never made a
first-person shooter before let's make
one right let's make one in 48 hours
because otherwise I might procrastinate
whatever this is like a dedicated kind
of thing right you have 48 hours to make
a game let's learn a new programming
technique let's learn a new programming
uncle game develop an algorithm whatever
there's a million different reason the
way you could be doing like them there
but the very important part of it is you
have to decide what that reason is all
right because that'll affect all of the
other I guess tips and stuff of that so
first of all once you get the theme
which you'll get as soon as the
competition starts you know what what is
the theme you need to analyze it okay so
for example the theme for the last item
there was ten seconds okay that that is
a very broad theme okay that could mean
a million different things it could mean
um well your game could be over in ten
seconds first of all the whole game
could go for ten seconds or you might
die if you're underwater for more than
ten seconds you might have to eat that
like the level might change every 10
seconds there's so many different kind
of things from that and that that's
really awesome in a way right there's
nothing concrete so you can really
change a lot of these things and and
think about it for easing other popular
one all the one that I did actually
first of all was that when you when
enemies I guess hit you you actually go
back ten seconds in time right that's
another really cool def a definition or
like I guess interpretation of that
theme so I'm the really important thing
is to take like ten minutes or so to
just plan and think about the theme what
does the theme mean okay if it's
something like evolution right that's
when you can get a bit more crazy with
it okay
you might want to open a dictionary and
actually define that word
for yourself because I mean we all know
what evolution means probably unless
you're not a native English speaker or
whatever but the dictionary can really
help us in the disorders as well to find
different angles at how we can approach
the thing right because again even with
evolution there's so many different I
guess the derivations and derivatives
and stuff like that of that theme and um
and it's really just important to see
every angle on it so that you can say
because that that'll help you again
that's the other thing right that'll
help you out a lot if you see other if
you're not sure what to do with this
theme you might find another angle into
it that will help you do that and that's
really important because the next part
of this is once you do settle on a nice
definition of this name or a nice
interpretation of the theme you want to
think of like a genre essentially and an
aesthetic okay so if you're honoring
what I mean by that is something like a
real-time strategy game a first-person
shooter a 2d kind of Pokemon RPG kind of
game right there's so many different
genres in game development of course
might wanna make a puzzle game and
action a horror whatever right there's
so many different there's 70 different
genres that you really have to pick one
that suits the theme as well as that's
the other important thing is something
that you can actually do okay so first
of all let's talk about the genres right
if a theme something what's something
it's something like evolution it might
be a lot harder to incorporate evolution
into something like a first-person
shooter game because of because of
certain technical requirements and all
that kind of thing but it also might be
a lot harder to incorporate a theme such
as space or world into a 2-d game right
because something that is 3d something
that you can feel a space that you
physically walk around in might feel a
lot more like I guess the feel of the
game would be a lot closer to the fame
the aesthetic the the you know the
feeling that you have the mood okay
that's what that's what I was looking
for the mood of the game would be much
different in a 3d kind of open-world you
know vast area game than in like a
little 2d top-down game okay that's
really important as well so you want to
think about that and the other really
important thing is the aesthetic if you
if you're making someone something like
a horror game you want to be able to UM
well I guess make it scary right if
you're making something colorful and
playful you want to make that colorful
and playful so the the thing that will
help you out was to with not only
choosing an aesthetic the demoing it is
just prototyping
all right prototyping is incredibly
important when you're doing a lot of
death and what I mean by prototyping is
not necessarily prototyping as in making
like a like a sketched you know kind of
scratch temporary version of your game
and then rewriting it from scratch or
saying now you don't have enough time to
do that what I mean is just Bosto bust
open like Photoshop or even better like
a pen and paper and just draw right Draw
Something and another awesome thing that
you can do is if you are making
something 3d not necessarily but let's
just say you are and you want to UM you
want to kind of visualize that then if
you do if you do happen to know how to
use 3d modeling applications such as 3d
studio Max or blender or whatever you
can quickly you know dish have a
prototype in there basically not
programming okay just aesthetical kind
of image creation you want to be able to
create like a quick prototype of what
the game will look like and again if you
do know applications like 3d studio max
that'll be really helpful for you
because you can even do some cool stuff
like animation and see exactly what you
want the your game to kind of look like
before it kind of gets made at yes if
that makes sense so prototyping is
really important because then you can
start away say you know this aesthetic
isn't gonna work or this is your honor
like I don't actually think like this
does this remind me of the theme when I
look at this image like not really so
there's a million different things that
you can do with prototyping and that's
why it's so powerful so that's why I
encourage you to do that as well okay
this is a really important point that's
coming up now is this achievable okay
that the goals that I have set for
myself the kind of game I want to make
is it actually gonna be achievable right
am I going to be able to do this within
48 hours okay that's that's probably the
most important point here really okay if
you've never made a first-person shooter
before and you want to make so and
suddenly you want to make a space
simulation first-person shooter
multiplayer game like you know like no
offense but you might not be able to do
that okay I'm gonna be really realistic
okay I think you probably wouldn't even
be able to do that in a week if you've
never done before okay and again you
might be able to pull something off but
something that actually looks good and
will be a playable game is very hard to
pull out it within 48 hours especially
if you're making it from scratch using
something like you unity for example
there might be a lot easier but it'll
still be very difficult so just make
sure that you um you kind of stay within
the within the boundaries of what you
know as well as you know just make sure
it's achievable essentially you don't
want to you don't have two hours left
and you you're just finishing up the
engine like you want to already have a
game done okay and that's very important
because I but see this ties back exactly
to why you're doing what I'm def you're
doing a lot I'm dare to learn a learn a
technique or to learn how to make a
first-person shooter because you've
never done it before that's completely
different
right in that case go for a try and make
that in fact that'll help you out a lot
because you might be able to actually
make something make like a prototype in
those 48 hours um but if you're doing a
lot um they're for the for the express
purpose of having a playable game done
or even you know scoring highly you want
to make sure that you actually you know
do something that you know how to do
okay and the other important thing is to
remember that this is 48 hours ok 48
hours is not much time why because first
of all probably around 30 hours of
actual development and that's pushing it
right let's just say you want to sleep
for like six to eight hours I mean me
personally if I sleep for probably less
than seven hours I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna be able to do anything the next
day right I'm gonna be pretty tired I'm
not gonna I'm just not gonna be at my
peak not to mention and my game
development let's program complex
algorithms kind of mood so um I need
about eight hours sleep usually that's
what I do with looking there right so
that takes out that's two nights right
well okay this is this is also different
right it depends what time zone you're
in for me the competition starts on
Saturday at like 12 p.m. and it finishes
Monday 12 12 p.m. right 48 hours so
that's Saturday night and Sunday night
eight hours plus eight hours is sixteen
hours so that's 16 hours normal left
with 32 hours let's talk about eating
let's say we're really fast with that
thirty hours okay so I'm gonna tie down
at about thirty hours and usually ends
up being
20 around 25 for me but let's just say
it's 30 hours okay that is not a lot of
time okay so you have to make sure that
whatever you choose to make if again you
actually want to finish a game if that's
your I guess purpose then make sure that
you actually um you actually you know
you can do it in 30 hours because you
don't wanna be stuck with something that
isn't exactly gonna work out if of
course working out is your is your will
okay so once you've once you've settled
on that stuff you've settled on
something that you think you might be
able to make it's time to choose a
development environment now what I mean
by that is do you want to use any
libraries do you want to use what
programming language do you want to use
do you want to use any kind of like I
guess systems and all engines that have
interfaces such as you as like the the
Unity game engine you know all that
stuff yeah you have to think about how
are you gonna make this okay now I'm
gonna talk about programming languages
in a separate video probably next
episode of this little mini series and
then I'm also going to talk about
software in another another episode of
this series so I'll talk about them
later but it's really important to be
able to choose the the kind of
programming language and libraries and
and stuff at the U that you want to use
for this and then finally pretty much
the last tip I have for you guys in
terms of planning is stick with what
you're familiar with okay if you want to
make a game right don't expect
everything to go right you're probably
gonna run into some even if you've done
it a million times before you've written
this exact same game you might you
probably will bump into a bug that is
essentially game breaking and you might
waste like five six hours on that I'm
not even kidding okay so because of that
you have to just make sure that you if
you do want to finish something stick
with something that you're familiar with
if you've been making but like
platformers and that's the extent of
your programming knowledge then make a
platformer right make a cool platformer
maybe maybe make it really new and and
sleek but make a cool platformer don't
go ahead and try and make a real time
strategy game because I guarantee to you
guys that it's going to be harder than
you think
okay a lot of diesel it's always harder
than you think when you look at it from
I guess a viewer point of view or
whatever 48 hours well 30 hours let's
just call it it's a lot of time it is 30
hours is tons but it might not be
because once you break it down into what
a game is made up of 30 hours is really
really small okay because I forget that
you need to make things like past like
assets and and well a lot of well I
guess assets and encourage what a game
is made up of but there's a lot of
little there's a lot of little things
that you might miss okay one of them for
example being exporting your game into a
correct format depending on what
programming language and system you use
to make the game this could be more
difficult okay if you're trying to set
up an applet in Java that could take you
a few hours so there's all these
different things to consider so the
bottom line here is if you want to
finish a game if making a game a
playable game from scratch is your like
your I guess goal and let them dare then
make sure you stick with something that
you're familiar with all right so that's
gonna wrap up this episode guys I'm not
normally won't call it an episode an
episode because it's just like one-off
videos even though there aren't they are
in a bit of a series of love embed tips
but if you guys enjoyed this video
please don't forget to hit the like
button and I'll see you guys tomorrow
with another one I'm dare tip goodbye